donc pour rêver on assassine us je vous
propose est de préparer et d'assemblée
du poisson fumé avec des écrevisses bleu
du carbet il va également des projets de
fin de saison comme le rose et le pays
au menu de restaurant michel cher voici
le marlin fumé et son écrevisses bleu du
carbet aux fluides saison un bouillon
bien salée à ébullition pour saisir le
crustacé
juste le temps qu'il rougissent et le
chef prépare la brunoise de légumes qui
garnira le roulé de marlin courgettes et
christophine pour le croquant et puis le
feu de la porte un petit peu de goût
anisé le giraumon un peu de sucre le
choix des légumes n'est pas anodin et le
fait de les mettre cru dans la
préparation non plus n'est pas anodin
une purée d'avocat est mélangée à la
brunoise
nous voilà prêts pour le volet de
poisson le roulé sa bosse cas compliqués
ne pas vouloir trop en mettre un
on va en mettre juste ce qu'il faut pour
qu'on puisse former un très beau tubes
comme ça un assaisonnement d'huile
végétale piment citron rb basilique pour
l'écrevisse le goût f1 pour un petit
budget un petit peu de poisson fumé un
petit peu des provinces le littoral mais
on a quand même chaud les produits
extrêmement frais pas qualitatif pour
autant on est sur une dizaine bureau
pour aux trois personnes - en
assaisonnement coulis de maracuja une
vinaigrette maison
le chef dépose son est mince et
d'écrevisses et légumes sur le roulé
puis son fameux jus avec rosa et entière
mixer et légèrement sucrée
à vous de jouer c'est important de
partager parce que quand on partage on
reçoit également donne également reçoit
et donc l'idée c'est de montrer un petit
peu ce qu'on peut faire et je crois
qu'il ya une réelle demande au niveau
des particuliers de vouloir apprendre
faire de
de belles recettes à la maison un peu de
truffes s'il y a des amateurs et pour
les cuisiniers en quête d'idées le chef
du conseil à de nombreuses vidéos de
recettes sur les réseaux sociaux
il a déjà plus de 5000 followers